about two minutes
I'll just get a signal
you say that's like a disco
I'll just go
good afternoon everybody
hi my name is Aziz Anna Bok
good afternoon again everybody my name
is Aziz an Aziz and I hope everybody had
a great lunch and we're gonna have a
great session coming up I am a faculty
at the Center for building performance
and diagnostic which is part of the
School of Architecture and we've been
working with the Scott Institute and
investigating researching and developing
technologies for energy reduction and in
demand-side management and what we're
looking at right now is commercializing
some of these technologies so it can be
available in the marketplace we do have
a set of outstanding panelists today to
debate and give us insight on the topic
of driving the built environment to
higher performance with energy-efficient
technologies and innovation our
panelists include Scott renautas who's
the associate vice chancellor for
facilities at the University of
Pittsburgh thank you for coming
Michael Barnard the project project
director at Oxford development key
rieflin Energy Manager at Giant Eagle
Aurora Sherrod executive director of
Green Building Alliance and David can
vice chancellor for infrastructure and
sustainability and the chief facilities
officer at the University of colder
about ball Arado
I like the title CFO as being chief of
facilities officer this fantastic so our
panelists came with very impressive
resumes and I would suggest that you
read them in your agendas or online also
we have Steve Gunter which is our
director of facilities and operations
and I'm gonna give the mic to him he'll
be moderating this session thank you
very much
you guys done and it's great to be here
with this panel I'm most excited about
these chairs and being the first group
to sit in them we were just at the my
Nana's house for Easter over the weekend
and I can tell you if these chairs were
in her living room we would not be
sitting in them we'd be looking at them
they're that beautiful so we're gonna
kick this off with a quote that sounds
like it's exactly suited for this
conference
it starts with working together we're
going to help bill help businesses
cities and states achieve their climate
goals and accelerate the transition to a
low-carbon future sounds like something
that the folks sitting in the audience
on stage here are already helping to do
that quotes actually from the University
of California system president Janet
Napolitano during a launch of the
University Climate Change coalition
better known now as you see three that
happened in February 2018 and that
coalition plans to pull together best
practices policies and recommendations
from all the UC three forums across the
country into a framework that can be
replicated around the world
so David first question goes to you your
Chancellor is one of 13 North American
leading universities that has joined the
push for research driven climate
policies and solutions focusing first
not just on your campus but your a
broader community tell us a little bit
more about you c3 how it's gonna drive
higher performance at your campus the
University of Colorado at Boulder
throughout history the university has
been a respected pillar in the community
across the globe our institutions are
driven by two fundamental activities
research and education we strive to
shape and educate the next generation of
citizens and leaders we're also about
discovery finding the truth sharing
knowledge and solving problems it's in
our DNA this is what we do every day day
in and day out
about a month ago as Steve mentioned
cu-boulder along with 12 other North
American universities from the U
Canada and Mexico announced the
formation of the University climate
change coalition which is rooted in the
idea that research university should
take on an expanded role in creating a
better understanding of climate change
through research data collection and
modeling that can inform action pull
particularly at the local and regional
level in a non-political way right it's
about facts so so what do we bring to
the table expertise in areas including
climate modeling energy storage
next-generation renewables smart energy
and efficient technology sustainable
transportation innovations as well as
deep understanding of the social
sciences economics policy and regulation
and it's not just us you know we have
partners across the country and across
the world
who can also do these things a real
example of what we're doing at
cu-boulder is a creation of a living
sustainability laboratory on our campus
where we plan to integrate research in
education into our daily operations to
create a fertile ground for innovation
entrepreneurship by bringing together
students faculty industry partners the
community venture capital with the goal
of taking Applied Research quickly into
commercialization so that we can
actually make a difference I'm
particularly excited about the
opportunity to enhance our operations as
well I'm also in charge of the
facilities through robust data analytics
machine learning the Internet of Things
artificial intelligence I think that
could be a game-changer in how we
actually operate our facilities more
efficiently as well as opportunities for
cost savings from an infrastructure
standpoint sustainability is intertwined
with everything we do from how we
operate retrofit and construct buildings
to how we plan for the future of the
campus it's not just about the
initiatives themselves but it's about
saving money using our resources more
efficiently I was saying the most
efficient building is the one that we
don't build enhancing resiliency and
leading by example in the community it's
about how we integrate the built
environment into the natural environment
we're also focused on how we can
closely integrates sustainability
education research and operations into a
seamless and well coordinated efforts
that's enduring collaborative and most
important impactful this means we must
make improvements on how we use our
facilities reducing energy and water
consumption integrating smart energy and
renewable technologies promoting
sustainability and procurement how many
folks actually buy stuff from Amazon in
all the packaging well I went to a
conference and I actually sat down with
Amazon said it can we do something
together to reduce that and as we do
this and we think about the investments
that we need to make in resources time
and effort it really is a balancing act
between what we need with what we want
with what we need to change and what we
can afford to fund in every case it has
to make business sense it has to pencil
out or it's not going to be sustainable
that's the challenge but the technology
exists the ideas are there the question
is how do we work together to move this
agenda forward another key area that
we're really focusing on is climate
resiliency and more broadly community
resiliency so this impacts everybody in
this room in one way or another this is
what keeps me up at night how do I make
sure that the doors are open at the
University this is what kept me up that
night when I worked at the White House
in my past life it was about the
continuity of the presidency and our
form of government now it's about
education and research brothers in this
room and maybe about keeping the
production line going or maybe just you
know making sure that you have power so
that you have heat at night in the
winter you know we we live in dynamics
and sometimes unforgiving environment so
if the lessons from hurricanes Katrina
sandy Harvey Maria don't wake us up what
we'll so we need to be prepared for
these disruptions we need to invest in
capabilities to help weather these
storms we need to work as a community to
identify and mitigate vulnerabilities or
at a minimum we need to be able to keep
our folks safe
be able to respond quickly and resume
normal operations as I said before
sustainability also means that our
solutions are cost-effective if this has
been a focus for our team at CU it's not
just about doing it it also has to make
sense we're focusing on becoming smarter
and more sustainable so that we can
become more resilient well we can't do
this in a vacuum we need to establish
nurture and expand research innovation
partnerships collaboration and to really
make an impact it has to be a
partnership between everybody that's in
this room and more importantly everyone
that's not in this room Thanks right
thank you David
and just as a reminder to the audience
that David's comments covered such a
broad range we are going to leave time
at the end for questions from the
audience please use the app you have
information on your table about how to
access it and won't be able to address
those questions at the end so moving
from a North American focus to a US
initiative in a turn to aurora talk
about 401 million square feet of space
that's united to try to catalyze
transformation in their built
environment I'm talking about the 2030
districts nationwide
we've got about one-fifth of that
overall portfolio here in Pittsburgh it
started about five years ago downtown as
it expanded include our neighborhood
here in the Auckland District within
Pittsburgh David talked about a number
of things that are going to happen
through the uc3 initiative and some of
those may have parallels to things that
have already started here in Pittsburgh
with the 2030 district what have been
some of the achievements for folks that
may not be familiar in the audience with
2030 and how you achieve that success
the portfolio that's included is so
diverse how do you drive success across
that diverse portfolio against such an
ambitious goal see if I could not hit
all of those things so taking a step
back a little bit for context for those
of you in the audience who aren't
familiar with it in the early 2000s
there was an architect named ed nazriya
out of New Mexico who did some back of
the envelope calculation said we're
gonna solve this whole climate change
thing what's buildings contribution
ran the numbers and said wow that is
significant our existing building stock
is consuming a ton we're continuing to
build and renovate new buildings over
time what needs to happen if we're going
to move buildings from being one of the
major contributors for climate change to
part of the solution is these 2030 goals
and the answer essentially in numbers
which I know a lot of you love and I do
too is carbon neutral for all new
construction by the year 2030 and 50%
reductions in energy use for existing
buildings below baselines by the year
2030 then you have to layer in 50%
reductions below baselines of water use
and transportation emissions and oh yeah
everybody needs to do it so when he does
in the early 2000s it went out to the
architecture urban planning community
and they said this is great and they
started working with some really
forward-thinking owners and institutions
across the country and just ticking away
one building at a time until an
individual named Brian Geller out of
Seattle I was walking around Seattle saw
their district steam plant and said ha
what if I talk to all the owners who are
connected to that facility and asked
them with their existing buildings to
contribute to these 2030 challenge goals
what would that do and he created the
first 2030 district the Seattle 2030
district in collaboration with the city
of Seattle in Pittsburgh we thought that
was such a great idea that we adopted
the model in 2012 we launched in August
2012 with 61 buildings in just over 30
million square feet so remember those
numbers and just in downtown we did it
quietly we talked to owners and
institutions who we thought would be
interested and it's a really interesting
conversation to go to a building owner
and say 50% reductions by 2030 energy
water transportation emissions and oh
yeah we're a green building organization
so we're gonna help you improve indoor
air quality as well because you can't
just seal up a building tape and a lot
of people were really interested
especially those who always thought that
they didn't have a seat at the green
building table because they weren't
eligible for a certification they
weren't moving fast enough they weren't
doing a major retro
fit or their performance was just not
very good so we created a safe space for
people to do this across sectors so
commercial office buildings cultural
institutions public buildings k-12
schools retail establishments and we
started making it voluntary safe
baseline benchmarks the you know it's
over time and there's a geographic
boundary and all of those things really
resonated with Pittsburghers so Steve
said 401 million square feet
internationally so there are 19 20 30
districts in North America Pittsburgh
has somewhere between 20 and 25% of all
the square footage committed to those
2030 challenge goals right here so we're
somewhere around 500 buildings and 80
million square feet if you want to know
the most up-to-date numbers you're gonna
have to wait two weeks until we unveil
our 2017 performance numbers on April
19th but it's really worked amazingly
well and Pittsburgh has just embraced
the approach the time period and they
really like that
it's performance-based it's not
prescriptive right so you're gonna hear
from a number of owners up here on the
stage today who have been doing these
things for a long time but as a small
nonprofit organization I can't go to any
one of them and say great here's your
list 1 2 3 do it in this order that that
doesn't work the way that buildings work
capital I just aren't that way operating
budgets aren't that way you have to let
people do it on their own time in their
own space in their own way when it's
right for them and then you give them
that network where they can learn from
each other and then because it's in
Pittsburgh we have a downtown boundary
and an Oakland boundary as we've
expanded the number of people that are
talking to each other has really
increased and they really enjoy that but
hearing it from each other is so much
more powerful than if I said it or do
you can't light says it or a service
provider says it it's just like very
different when Pitt and John Eagles sit
down and are talking to each other I'm
like oh is this what you're doing for
your coolers I could do that in my
establishments and it's kind of amazing
the takeaways that you see from those
types of interactions I think I had
everything that I think you did it's
great another key to success here in
Pittsburgh I don't think the district
boundaries cross a bridge or a tunnel
and so me not yet yeah and no spoiler
alert about the results coming out in
two weeks all right fantastic
well Scott your campus is signed up for
the 2030 district and there's been a
number of other really exciting things
happening at the University of
Pittsburgh let's start out with some
background going back 15 years ago on
your campus in 2003 you your camp has
established the mascara Center for
Sustainable innovation that's your home
for education and research related to
sustainability five years after that
your faculty got involved and the Senate
passed a statement on sustainability in
conjunction with issuing the first
greenhouse gas inventory or your large
and expansive campus covering all facets
of your operations we advanced another
five years beyond that to the next
milestone your campus published its
report on sustainability which for the
first time ever put in print all of the
achievements related to sustainability
across your campus life talking about
research talking about housing talking
about student talking about justice just
as well as you're talking about energy
to add to all of that this last December
your Chancellor issued from his desk the
Pitt sustainably sustainability plan
which describes itself as quote a
strategic framework that calls for
dramatic improvement in sustainability
across our university by 2030 know no
coincidence on date but also when I got
that milestone out there the thing that
resonated with me most are those words
dramatic improvement stated from the
Chancellor's desk in the opening letter
in the report you've already done so
much on your campus obviously that's a
call to do so much more can you tell us
a little bit about the plan specifically
about the things that you're going to be
doing to help to achieve the
Chancellor's goals great thank you very
much Steve
so it was a
a new plan it's the first comprehensive
sustainability plan for the University
of Pittsburgh I worked with the
university-wide sustainability committee
formed in fall of 2016 just a year later
last this last fall we took the plan to
the Chancellor and to your point he said
it's not dramatic enough it's not old
enough
I said whoa I think it is he said now I
think you need to
and so we've fully embraced in print the
2030 district goals and he said I want
to see a 50% reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions I want to see 50% reduction or
a 50% of your electrical power supplied
by renewable energy I want to see it's
50 cubed that make sure I get them all
here because they're relatively new I
left the press at least 50% below the
national average for energy use
intensities now we got a little bit of
homework that we're still working on and
what does that last one mean the other
roofs are pretty clear in either way
those 50 percents in the fourth one that
I didn't mention that I'm not going to
talk about is water intensity but all of
those are significant changes for a very
diverse you know 12 and a half million
square-foot university with buildings
dating back you know about a hundred
years to brand-new modern buildings
which are less challenging but right off
the bat what we and we heard that a
little bit in David's talk what we
realize is one is these aspirational
goals are going to cost and they're
going to benefit but they're also going
to cause and so we feel it's incumbent
upon us to figure out
you know what that what that advantage
is and is it worth the cost for the
University now we've committed to those
aspirational goals since the Chancellor
signed that and it's right there up
front in page one since he signed those
ambitious goals we've been meeting every
other week in facilities management on
that energy piece on those 450s and what
we've what we found is you know despite
having signed up for the 2030 we never
really had a comprehensive
implementation plan roadmap on how we're
going to get there so that's what we've
been doing you know every other week
since then we've implemented a what we
call project payback fund so the
university has committed five million
dollars for energy projects that we'll
pay back in five to seven years we
haven't nailed down what that timeframe
is obviously is we're new to this newly
implementing this we feel there's a lot
of low-hanging fruit and hopefully we'll
be able to come up with some rapid
payback quickly so what are we doing
what are some of those energy projects
were looking at to use that that part of
a project payback funds we're looking at
continuous commissioning fact just this
morning before I came here I was in the
meeting looking at another approach at
continuous commissioning which would
look promising we're looking at doing
energy audits we've conducted the
initial energy audit 16 of our buildings
out of our 100
thirty some buildings did an initial 16
what we called our energy hogs and David
will remember that term from the Navy
but those are our most wasteful
buildings looking at an EU eye
perspective and so we've got those ECMs
we're gonna lump those in along with
some approach for continuous
commissioning and we are also going to
do campus-wide lighting survey we're
gonna look at tying that because this
you know we got to show payback so that
lighting survey will include some select
replacement so I social energy savings
and we didn't want this energy project
payback fund to be tied to just doing
studies you know we wanted it to
literally each piece of that payback and
then one of the big things that we're
doing is trying to figure out what are
our target EU is across the campus as I
mentioned we got some buildings at about
a hundred years old some buildings that
are much newer so are as you can imagine
our energy use intensity is it's all
over the mat and we're trying to find
those targets that are reasonable and
worth the investment in those older
buildings and then seeing what we can
also do even in the newer buildings to
tighten that up and so we are in the
process right now of trying to define
with our design partners what a status
quo a better and a best might cost and
what those target EU eyes would look
like and so then you would as we go
through the design process we would say
hey you know we want you to in the
schematic design in the concept phase
give us some preliminary numbers for
what is a status quo a better and a
passive so we're pretty excited about
that we're in the infancy stages a lot
of us we're in the infancy stages but
again that that sustainability plan has
has kicked us all in the behind to get
going and so similar to Dave and I were
comparing notes similar to the
University of Colorado
you know we're revamping our design
standards to make all of our buildings
perform battle and I think that's great
it's amazing how a commitment from the
top can create alignment and break down
silos within a university and bring the
whole campus together against a unified
goal and the planning is incredibly
important implementation is what
delivers on the outcome that people are
promising under the 2030s okay let's
switch to you and talk a little bit
about implementation the drive in the
built environment it's not just about
large institutions campuses it gets down
to individual in your case individual
stores and making them perform that can
not only be a good thing for the
environment but it can be great for
making your business competitive and
changing the guest experience so the
question remains though how do we drive
those buildings if we look at the goals
overall on where we need to get to as a
country buildings consume 30 percent of
electricity or 30 percent overall the
energy they're not moving as fast as
they should in terms of their share of
the overall energy marketplace
sometimes that gap has to do not just
with the planning but with the
implementation of it you've got about
400 retail locations across four states
that's a huge portfolio and not all
connected and nestled within a closed
geographic proximity how do you drive
implementation and success across like
giant Eagles Steve thank you and it is
really challenging when you have so many
different locations and you know how to
save energy it's just going and how do
you actually flip those switches change
out the equipment and actually make that
improvements really challenging so we're
really fortunate in Giant Eagle we have
that top-down commitment our
or cretin or CEO see sustainability is
really a strategic priority and she sets
the expectation that we are going to be
continuously improving our energy
consumption so that makes it very easy a
giant eagle to explain why we need to do
that as a result of that top-down
commitment we have this wonderful
cross-functional team at Giant Eagle and
I think this is really key to
implementing projects so on an ongoing
basis people that work in sustainability
engineering procurement energy
procurement and operations meet on a
continuous basis to evaluate different
projects and what we do is then
prioritize projects based on what
technology can we roll out to all the
stores what technology applies to our
most energy-intensive stores and how
easy is it to implement it what's the
payback associated with it because we
really want to implement the projects
that are going to touch the most
locations most dramatically first to
generate the most savings and then we
can take that savings and use it to
justify additional projects as well so
really that cross-functional team is
really key in implementing projects one
tool that we use to gain acceptance
around projects is we always pilot a
technology I can pretty much guarantee
you that we'll never blindly roll out a
project all of our locations without
really rigorously testing it I love
doing pilots because it's a way of
engaging people that aren't really
familiar with energy and sustainability
to show the value of a project one of my
favorite days that I've ever spent
working at Giant Eagle was the day that
we were doing an LED pilot on our sales
floor and what we did is we went into
one store and we retrofitted half of the
sales floor with LEDs and the other half
we left as fluorescence we then invited
all the executives to literally walk the
store so they could literally see pre
and post post project what we were
trying to do and at the same time I
showed them we have real time energy
honoring on all of our stores so I used
that as a really valuable tool for
telling the energy story and I was
literally able to show them exactly how
much energy we reduced they could see
aesthetically this won't help hurt the
stores it's gonna really improve our
guest experience and oh by the way this
is we're actually saving that much
energy they could physically see it so I
think that's really important when you
pilot projects it also gives you the
opportunity for feedback which is very
important so literally that day
executives were going up to guess and
asking what do you think about these
lights do you like it you know what I
mean so it was really a it was really
nice because we were able to get that
feedback and go to team members that are
gonna be in the stores every single day
and ask how they feel about it so a lot
of times that's really helpful because I
mean you're when you're in that
highlighting stage you can refine the
rollout before you you know roll out
something to all the stores then realize
oh shoot I wish I hadn't made these
three changes before doing so one thing
that's really important when you're
talking about implementing projects is
to talk about all of the benefits
associated with the project so it's not
just energy you have that aesthetic
value you might have maintenance savings
so it's really important that when you
have that cross-functional team it
enables you to look at a project very
holistically and talk about all the
benefits associated with it one thing
that's also really key into implementing
rollouts is to kind of minimize how many
rollouts you have to do so when you're
doing something like a lighting project
you want to see are there any kind of
peripheral projects that I want to pull
into this rollout so a really great
example is where towards the end of
implementing LED across all of our sales
floor when we were at the beginning of
that projects we looked at the lighting
controls and we actually realized we
want to pair a dimming system with this
LED retrofit because we can maximize the
savings of the project we're reducing
upfront costs because now we have one
rollout instead of two rollouts so
that's something that's really important
you're implementing a project you want
to make sure what other projects do I
want to wrap in to this roll up one
thing that I don't think people talk
about enough but I worry about it all
the time
locations is how can we simplify energy
projects in terms of implementation so I
don't know hopefully people are familiar
with Giant Eagle
but here in the city if you think about
all of our stores they're vastly
different from one another if you want
an example go to the Giant Eagle in
Squirrel Hill and then go to our shady
side Market District location incredibly
different stores so when we do something
like an LED rollout I don't have the
time and internal resources to
necessarily do a custom solution at
every single store so how can I actually
roll this out in a time effective manner
I can't be upgrading our stores for the
next five years I need to get it done
within a year so this ties in to the
dimming systems that we paired with our
LED retrofit rather than pick let's say
hundreds of different fixtures that we
would need to actually implement this
rollout we were able to narrow it down
to ten but but then because we have the
dimming control system we can then
custom the light levels at every single
store so it makes it very easy to do the
rollout and meet the needs of every
single store without having to go to
every single store do a lighting layout
to a light analysis and things like that
so it helps really ease the
implementation one thing you also have
to work with is all of your partners
when you're getting ready to do an
implementation project you have to
really be able to trust your vendors you
want to partner with your utilities if
you're pursuing things like rebates make
sure you're really getting all the value
you can and also set expectations set
expectations for your vendor in terms of
timeline in terms of what you actually
want the outcome to be so everyone is on
the same page and then when you actually
start to implement the project make sure
you're in constant communication make
sure you're actually following your
timeline make sure you're sharing
lessons learned if you have one crew
that they found an efficiency and
they're able to you know reduce install
time by 10% you want to make sure that
all the install teams are sharing from
that knowledge and you're benefiting
from it so once you're underway with
your role you want to be in constant
communication
make sure you're actually implementing
your plan as necessary and one important
aspect of implementing projects that I
think a lot of times people forget about
is when it's done
following up reporting on it you know
one thing that I always kind of laugh
about it is when it comes to energy fit
and see a lot of people are focused on
the P&L statements and I always track
energy cost energy consumption and
energy price so as we're doing this LED
retrofit I'm all over the stores for
watching their films watching their
energy line and there was a handful of
stores that I noticed their energy costs
went up after this LED project so I
start stressing out I go into all the
bills and I realize okay they actually
reduce consumption to line items
increased to the point it completely
negated from a cost perspective our LED
rollouts and then I actually had to
create the story internally and say
listen this turned from a cost savings
to cost avoidance and actually show
people we absolutely reduced and the
project was successful and this is what
would have happened if we hadn't done it
so it's really important that you're
communicating with your vendors
communicating internally on the success
of a project you also want to monitor it
to make sure you actually did receive
that savings for a lot of projects you
can install controls incorrectly and
then they're actually not functional so
you always want to do that due diligence
after you implement a project
communicate that success I'm sure it's
working as it should be and that eases
kind of when you have your next project
because you already have that internal
buying which is so critical in to
getting more project stuff thanks Katie
I think it's amazing how Giant Eagle has
such a commitment to brand standards but
that's actually complexity in trying to
implement projects because you've
customized your brand to all the
different real estate that you occupy
and and you've done it in a way that has
not diminished
best experience when you've rolled out a
project across the world I've been with
Giant Eagle for about three years and
when I started at Giant Eagle I was like
we have to have kind of like groups of
stores and it took me about a year to
really accept that everyone one of our
community is that we're in is different
and every one of our stores in those
communities really see I only thought
that existed on a college campus you
guys can write everything every building
is unique it happens at Giant Eagle too
talking about unique buildings Michael
I'll turn to you for last panel question
build smart build sustainable operate
efficiently those are words that
resonate with this audience but it's
also rip directly from your from
corporate material from Oxford
development but sometimes the market
don't reward cost or complexity
complexity associated with the type of
innovations that we'd all like to push
so you're a private developer tell me
what limitations you face when you're
implementing new methodologies or
technology what approach does Oxford use
to drive improvements in buildings
performance while still facing that
challenge well I think in general for us
the the biggest challenge is like any
other project construction projects
they're very difficult to start and
they're difficult to start because of
budget because of schedule and so
whenever we're trying to implement new
methodologies technologies you know
construction practices it may be a
little counterintuitive to the design
and construction process to say well how
do we reevaluate what we did the last
time and that's going to stretch the
schedule potentially scratch it the
stretches the budget it provides
uncertainty which tends to be the the
enemy of the investors the lenders and
the folks that are actually writing the
checks so what we've done at least is
tried to look at it in more of an
incremental approach you know how can we
take the next project to a little higher
standard we're very fortunate we have
leadership in our company who has
stepped up and you know is looking at it
from what's the right thing to do
for people for the planet for you know
the whether it be 2030 district lead
certification the p4 measures here in
Pittsburgh those are all things that are
very important to us and when it comes
from the top down we look for ways to
take the next step in that direction but
again I think the biggest challenges for
us are proving proving it out in an
efficient process and then also being
able to execute the prop the projects
efficiently so that they're successful
in the end
and then obviously lead to the next
project so we aren't certainly aren't
doing as much as we'd like I know from
when we look at it internally but we
threw that incremental approach it's
we've been very successful in elevating
and going beyond what the minimum we
have to do and hopefully starting to
achieve more of those aspirational
standards and and we're we're fortunate
here locally to have resources that can
assist us with that and can also kind of
set expectations from a market
standpoint that are above that of kind
of the cheapest ability you can build by
code so we leverage those relationships
and hopefully are proving to be you know
one of the leaders in act in that arena
that way fantastic it not being able to
do everything we'd like I think is a
common theme across the folks here up on
stage as well as in the audience we've
got about five minutes left so I think I
have time for one question that's come
in from the audience and I'm just going
to toss that to the panel at large
please any of you jump in on this the
question is does making building energy
buildings energy efficient lead to a
rise in either the construction or other
operating costs and if they do how do
you motivate your administration or
prospective owners into taking on those
higher costs anybody Steven I'll jump on
that first type yes
and particularly on the operational side
I learned that as I mentioned we have a
wide range of portfolios that's the
older buildings as Aurora said you know
they didn't have to take in the same air
changes that we have to take in now and
so when we remodel those we put
high-efficiency systems in but guess
what I'm taking out window air
conditioners and it's or radiator units
I'm replacing window air conditioners
I'm adding air conditioner window air
conditioning when there wasn't and so my
operating costs go up and I'm learned I
learned you got to be very careful on
how to questions on how you present that
data and I got wrapped around the axle
the first time I tried to explain it
just the 5x to the board and so I've
learned my lesson and it's you have to
be careful you have to tell the story on
how how that energy cost is is better it
might be more for that space than it was
but we bought a benefit so it becomes a
cost avoidance rather than a cost
savings
I think it's yes and no and so you know
the example of the LED lights is a great
example right so make cost more upfront
but the lifecycle cost may be
significant or especially you have to
pay you know eighty to eighty dollars an
hour for electrician to come out and
real amp you know every two or three
years versus every 15 year right so I
think you know what Scott talked about
what we're working on as well changing
the design criteria so that we actually
are more thoughtful and what we put in
there and then I think more importantly
going from what you talked about the
first cost of construction to lifecycle
cost and so looking at the entire system
from you know when you build it when you
plan it and build it to disposal
and looking at the lifecycle of the
people and seeing what's the right
investment to make in doing that in the
early stages of planning I think is the
direction that we need to head in and so
the focus has always been on the first
cost how can I save money on this you
know multi-million dollar project well
you may be saving five hundred thousand
dollars but you're gonna be paying eight
million dollars over sixty years of the
life of the building which is probably
not the smartest investment so I think
that approach is so we answer this
question every day up down in sideways
and we make the case for it with all
sorts of different owners and sizes and
types and the answer is it doesn't have
to but sometimes it does and sometimes
people get super excited about
everything that they're doing and they
want to change the paradigm and that's a
really important thing that I think
David just hit on is you know this
question about buildings consume 40
percent of all the energy that we use in
the United States we've been using that
statistic in the green building industry
for 25 years and the number hasn't
changed that's the problem right because
we're not shifting we're just like doing
these incremental reductions and this is
why things like the Passivhaus movement
has really resonated with some people
because it takes an entirely different
approach it's like great take energy use
cut it down by half at the beginning a
minimum could have got my half maybe all
the way down to 10% and then have your
most efficient building layer on
renewables and don't worry about it
because you're building an asset and I
think that's one of the things that we
sometimes forget about in the building
industry it's not just about economics
we're building somewhere that's gonna be
a place it's going to contribute to that
community and our environment for 50 100
200 years and we really need to be
treating our buildings like assets
as lifecycle assessment also talking
about risk as well so talking about what
happens if energy prices double in ten
years
we're planning on this building being
here for another twenty years so you
know both in terms of energy costs in
terms of sustainability in terms of
resilience we also have to be talking
about risk especially when it comes to
new construction and we're gonna be
stuck with that asset for decades to
come
this is really the best opportunity to
avoid some of that risk so we're not
implementing projects halfway through
and then this benefit from doing it from
the beginning well I agree yeah I agree
with everything that's been said I think
that the challenge again is also there
certainly as that first cost and it is a
challenge but the and the lifecycle cost
is something that needs to be evaluated
and that's something that at least in a
lot of the markets that we deal with
changing that paradigm because so much
of our lifecycle costs are reliant on
tenant behaviors and you know where this
where the savings are actually realized
and how that affects kind of the success
of the project on the economic model and
it's something that we're working to try
to get better at it's a little different
than an institutional scenario where you
know the same people that own it live
there and you know can be controlled
maybe a little bit better one of the
biggest differentiators for us is the
would be in some of the amenities and
the the attractiveness of the property
so some of the low-hanging fruit whether
it's you know enhanced energy
performance that the tenants realize on
you know where we can do it
incrementally evie stations that are put
in our properties things like that that
they see and we start to see the tenants
that want it pay maybe a slight premium
for it that's where it helps to feed the
model back and it's easier to take those
things on at the beginning thank you I
think we're at the conclusion of time so
I want to thank the panel for the things
that you did before today at your
respective institutions or organizations
and the leadership that you exhibit to
help drive this important aspect of the
built and buyer
higher-performance thanks for your
insights for the audience today looking
forward to interacting with you more
throughout the rest of the conference
[Applause]
to start
okay hi everybody hello
we've got more there's more there's more
to come I'm Karen Lightman I'm executive
director of Metro 21 smart cities
Institute here at Carnegie Mellon
University we are a strong partner of
the Wilson East Scott Institute and
we're really excited to be here a part
of energy Week and it's my honor and
delight to be introducing this panel
let's see our tie our panel that's
coming up is managing energy and water
infrastructure and I'm excited to be
introducing the folks to my left
including Peter frisk who's gonna be
today Fisk
brother who's going to be today's
moderator peter is the director of water
and energy resilience Research Institute
at the Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratories he is the director of wer
RI and his goal is to orient and align
the water related research programs to
address critical gaps in reliability
efficiency sustainability of wanted
water energy systems in California as
well as the country then to his left is
Herve Busan I think I got it right right
we rehearse this he's vice president and
process engineering at Veolia water
solutions and technologies since 2005
Herve has served as the vice president
of process engineering solutions of
technologies and he's a member of the
executive committee of the company and
then to his left is Megan mount mater
that rhymes with water
she's associate professor civil and
environmental engineering and public
policy here at Carnegie Mellon
University Megan's research probes
pathways for meeting water demand in a
carbon-constrained world by optimizing
policies evaluating efficiency and
developing and modeling materials to
maximize performance and then to her
right is Venki Sharma he's the president
and CEO of aqua tech van
he has been at the helm of aqua tech for
more than 20 years so no longer a
startup right and he's transforming it
from a small regional manufacturer of
industrial water treatment equipment to
a leader in global water industry with a
focus on solving water scarcity issues
please join me in welcoming the panel
and Peter take it away thanks very much
for coming out today right when we are
off stage LV you said that you've been
in R&D in water for essentially your
whole career but she said now is one of
the most exciting times to be in water
tell us why yes so I was in Canada in
our indeed and in France I was heading
the R&D center for our company and I
came to the US and I am an R&D guy in
which sometime I busted your two R&D I
can assure you that I have seen a lot of
innovations but what I see today is the
background innovations in material
sciences biotechnology Computer Sciences
digital sciences is so exciting because
we have a lot of things that our
industry will be able to use in the
future so when I see young kids in
university is not I really tell them you
are lucky because you're gonna have very
interesting bright future and the water
is no longer considered you know a small
thing every industry seeing water our
strategic so it's a fantastic time and
then key you now lead a company that is
innovating in the water space I noticed
in our our previous title it was titled
managing energy and water infrastructure
but it said managing energy comma and
water infrastructure so why don't you
tell us a little bit about where you see
the emerging connections between water
and energy in particular with with in
Pennsylvania it's Mike working yes I
think that energy and water historically
and more so today are very intertwined
and we call it the energy water Nexus
energy requires lots of water and
treating water whether it's for air
pollution whether it's for high purity
requires lots of energy in Marcellus
Shale as an example in Pennsylvania
energy extraction for shale gas shale
oil requires tremendous management of
water whether it be for treating and for
the reuse of frack water or production
brines which ultimately are end-of-life
type water and so there's a lot of
recycle and reuse treatment and there's
a lot of ultimately more advanced
technology treatment emerging as a area
and amarka you know I don't like to call
you can't generate generalize Marcellus
Shale you really have micro markets that
develop based on where the concentration
of TDS is in a market why don't what you
define well I was gonna say TDS is total
dissolved or dissolved solids in other
words the amount of salt and dissolve
things right so typically you know
southwestern Pennsylvania will have an
average total dissolve solids level at
Lava average distance from disposal and
it'll have average water availability
and depending on all of those things the
need for advanced technology will will
happen you know the amount of brine so
in other words you have different
flavors of water even across a single
producing area call them micro mark
micro markets Micro and and then
different environments around the United
States will have different flavors of
water as well absolutely I mean if
you're in the Permian Basin it's a water
scarcity driven market in Pennsylvania
we're typically a disposal driven market
or lack of disposal so in power oil and
gas is largely the same and electron is
the same no matter where you go but in
water things are very different Megan in
Pennsylvania what challenges do you see
that that gives for water infrastructure
if the conditions and the chemistry's of
water can be so variable so
it's on okay and as thank you is
alluding to in in the produced water
treatment space especially there is
quite a bit of variability both
spatially but also temporally and which
means that your treatment technologies
need to respond to very very different
total dissolved solids
concentrations over the lifespan of the
well Megan why don't you explain a
little bit about so our audience is
familiar with what happens when you're
at the various stages in oil and gas
what types of water go in and how do
they come out and how do they change
just briefly yeah sure so when you are
injecting your frack fluid that may be a
freshwater source that's being used to
suspend the profit and the chemicals
that are used in the hydraulic
fracturing operation or some of that
water may actually be recycled so we'll
come back to that in just a second
you also have formation water or water
that is present in the shale itself and
so after the fracturing operation
actually happens you get flowback water
the composition of which looks something
like the composition of the water that
you put down the well in the first place
and then over time it evolved to look
much more like the water that's present
in the formation itself these shales
have a number of different minerals that
that make up the rock including large
concentrations of clay sometimes which
have lots and lots of ions in sort of
trapped in that clay layer and and that
is most likely the source of a lot of
the high concentration dissolved solids
that we see in the flowback water here
in the Marcellus it sounds like a
terrible treatment challenge and and in
some respects is is this putting new
demands on the technology for water
treatment eleve as leader in R&D and one
of the largest and most sophisticated
water technology companies in the world
how is that challenging the traditional
water treatment systems yeah I think you
know what we have best available
technologies that have been established
and so for a long time but when we treat
this type of
you waters which change like we're
saying Megan definitely you really need
to rethink your your standard offering
you need to optimize it you need to
tweak it what the customers want what
the industry want is resilience
reliability you know every day the plan
is not running is it's very important so
I think the way you design a plan for
this type of application in Tanzania is
different from what we've been using to
do in other places and truly we are
learning also everyday as you get
confronted with the industry you know
how to optimize this train yeah you see
a lot of two types of technologies I'll
stop there but you have technologies
that are implemented at the early stage
of fracking which is very dispersed
small mobile units you know that's gonna
go and then at some point when you start
to do more and more and you have more
flow then you're gonna start to see
bigger plants and the technologies we
use our state-of-the-art technology will
unit evaporation mount brains I mean
those are complex so so one of the
things that a lot of people might not
realize is that the volumes of water
relative to the hydrocarbons you get I'm
trained as a geologist but even I was
surprised by the volume of water
relative to oil that comes out of the
ground even in a quote-unquote normal
well so many oil and gas companies
really are in the water business whether
they like it or not
Venki um have you seen innovation from
the oil and gas industry with respect to
how they treat their water or are they
relying on us to solve all these
problems for them I think oil and gas
producers are demanding innovation from
ourselves field via and other players in
the market they're demanding technology
innovation they're demanding business
model innovation
herve referred to mobility mobile taking
technology into mobile assets has become
an important aspect one of the things as
far as customers innovating themselves
to your question Peter they have you
know what we see emerging is really
depending on the recipe that a and this
becomes fairly complex for a producer
because he's thinking about how often
he's
to have to restate and the the well as
well as his yields and the more
sophisticated producers are really
demanding designer water what we call
designer water a very specific recipe
and that's part of the innovation that's
going on and that's demanding technology
innovation from ourselves and others so
you have to sort of become the barista
from hell you've got an infinite variety
of water coming in and you've got to
make an infinite variety of different
flavored drinks going out well keep in
mind most of the water we deal with is
three or four times more concentrated
than sea water
so sea water is typically around 35,000
TDS total dissolved solids
we're dealing with one hundred and forty
thousand on average TDS so it's totally
different than the industrial the worse
than the dead survey and yeah and you
have to purify that you have to purify
that - drinking water standards that
sounds like a very complicated and and
and and perhaps insurmountable - how
scum is drinking water - standards
because of the technologies deployed
membranes evaporation eventually yield
drinking water standards you don't think
the producers don't require it it's an
outcome of what processes are demanded
by the situation so wait a minute so we
don't necessarily need to treat to a
drinking water standard if your disposal
if you're discharging you might you
might yes okay Megan this issue of
treating two different levels how does
that pose challenges and opportunities
for Rd and and what new what new
exciting frontiers do you see emerging
from the science side of things yeah so
I think that the first frontier is
actually avoiding treatment altogether
or minimizing treatment treatment is
very very costly it's also energy
intensive and it's hard to do at the
distributed scale that's relevant to
most of these oil and gas operations in
a place like Pennsylvania and so the
first innovation is really in being able
to reuse that flowback water despite its
high concentration of TDS there's been a
lot of innovation in the formulations
that companies have
used and we've moved from jelf racks
which require low divalent ion
concentrations now that's a lot of
thethe at's a lot of technical speak so
GL fracked are you saying you put jelly
in the ground it's a cross-linked
polymer that's that's much better thank
you Megan yeah the first innovation is
really in moving towards water reuse
operations there's also been a lot of
innovation in how you treat a high
salinity brine so our lab is doing some
work in I'm using low temperature heat
to drive membrane distillation processes
we're doing some work in how to use
existing reverse osmosis membrane
equipment in new configurations to be
able to push the upper limit of that
total dissolve concentration solid
concentration beyond where reverse
osmosis currently works and then finally
I think that there's a lot of
opportunity still yet to be tapped in
really understanding how to recover some
value from these brines
and there are colleagues that I have in
the civil environmental engineering
department and that are doing quite a
bit of work in where the element
recovery from those Brian's ghave Veolia
is an international company and now
we're talking specifically about some of
the challenges and opportunities of
dealing with water in the energy sector
in the United States can you look at
other countries as Veolia working
elsewhere in the world and are you
seeing some interesting examples or
lessons that can be inform the United
States or are we really on the forefront
of dealing with some of these challenges
yeah I mean there is a lot of it depends
the scope you take I mean if you take
shale gas definitely I think here is at
the front of what's happening if you
enlarge to wet gas and then you are not
shale and then then we have seen we've
seen projects in the world we have seen
very interesting projects they are all
very different the regulations are
different the but the funny thing is the
technologies base is similar but to make
the process resilient you know small
changes are very very
important I think for me the keys so we
are in the world there is a lot
demanding yeah there is a lot of
interesting projects world why we are
also working a lot in the power industry
in general you know power plants so we
could enlarge it but for shale gas I
mean here is is really yeah they you you
bring up the the point that water and
energy are interconnected from across
number of sectors not just oil and gas
and in fact in the United States one of
the biggest revelations was when
droughts come oftentimes power plants
are not able to operate at peak capacity
because they utilize just the existing
river water which may end up really
flowing at a much lower level yeah New
Mexico you know right now at the u.s. is
amazing so I come from North Carolina as
you can tell for myself I your
excellency they are the problem is too
much water in too short time you know
when we have but then you know New
Mexico and so I think in the u.s. you
have these amazing problems linked to
water sometimes not enough sometimes too
much definitely a big yeah talk to
Houston about too much water and can
happen Vicki it has been said that the
water industry is very slow-moving and
not terribly innovative and yet you've
been your leading a company that is in
this space
do you is it personal is that a fair
statement or is it not quite true and if
it is true how does a technology
innovator be effective if the
environment is slow-moving I think that
in general that the water industry is
has that historical brand of being slow
moving on technology I think ultimately
we're driven by our customers demands we
have kind of three mega trends that are
going on one is water scarcity that's
been increasing that's driving
innovation we have regulation and then
we have ultimately higher purity demands
from processes that are driving
innovation demand so
more than ever today as irv a referred
to I would say we're in the golden age
of water technology in areas such as
electrochemistry area such as material
science areas such as membranes bio tech
digitization automation chemistry all
converge into solutions because all of
these require solutions and kind of I
touched on automation but today we have
the issue of how we can drive automation
towards optimization and robustness and
delivering performance these are
frontiers and water that exists so I
think today like no other is the
frontier of it's a golden age for water
that's great and and Megan are you
seeing that from undergraduates at CMU
or is the message not out yet do you
have a line around the around the
hallway outside your office seeking to
become majors in your discipline well I
see that caval is here instead of being
at class but it's great to see you come
out uh-huh I do see a lot of excitement
and particularly among students that
that are interested in engaging in the
research space so I think that as more
and more undergraduates come in with
interest in in the water space finding
ways to link that research to companies
and and to provide a path forward for
them to continue innovating in their
professional careers is really important
mm-hmm thank you here people on this
panel may are probably well aware and
maybe some of you in the audience that
Cape Town South Africa is facing a dire
crisis with respect to water supply and
I'm curious for each of you to share
with us first of all we all in the water
industry know this issue but what do you
think the lessons are for Cape Town
situation and you know just wanted to
sort of pass that question every when I
say Cape Town you say what beautiful
city yes it is no I think planning is
very important you know water should not
taken for granted we need to look at
data we need to plan and we need to
understand in the case of Cape Town you
know they had planned see you cannot
plan everything you know sometimes
Australia built an incredible capacity
of design nation plans which was good
for an industry and suddenly started to
rain a lot as if that's right It was as
if they made a big pile of money on the
beach and it set it on fire and the
rains came from the sky so that's a bad
example so but I think we really need to
plan to think I think also what's
important Singh energy don't sing on
your water it costs a lot of energy to
desalinate seawater so what about the
reuse I think we you should be
definitely a big part of the city
thinking because reuse is cheaper in
terms of energy it has less you know
easier you know way cheaper so uh so I
think some of our cities have not
planned enough in the u.s. we know that
in terms of water infrastructure
unfortunately there hasn't been enough
renewal so the underground
infrastructure which is in other pipes
the are totally some of them are need
change and the budget needed to really
upgrade that is is very it's a very big
budget so and then think innovative
don't think they like the old ways do we
need this mega centralized structures or
do we need more decentralization and
then dispersal I mean all that needs to
be carefully everything yeah okay
Megan I say Cape Town you say I say that
we really need to think about resiliency
and diversification this is a term that
Herve used earlier but resiliency
incorporates tapping a number of
different sources whether that's
groundwater whether that surface water
reservoirs whether that's water reuse or
whether that's water desalination
particularly in a changing climate when
we don't know exactly how precipitation
is likely to change over the next 50 to
100 we're likely to need to have a wide
portfolio of water supply options to be
able to ensure resiliency to that
changing climate
I say Cape Town Venki use
a Singapore tell us more I say
prevention through strategies similar to
what's in Singapore is undertaken
because they've taken up a multi-tap you
know this is a island country that
should have only focused on desalination
they focused on everything possible on
water and energy efficiency innovation
they're constantly threatened by
Malaysia of shutting down the tap so you
know they're a very they've they set out
a very compelling blueprint for planning
and it's a mix of trying to drive down
the cost of desalination through power
reduction it's through it's things like
me water where we change our thinking
we're we know what's that term again new
water and like right here new water yes
no no K but basically it's taking
recycled water whether it's industrial
sewage or others and recycling it and
you know understanding that water is
water and if it's chemically clear and
drinkable then you do it so so Singapore
has actually pioneered direct potable
reuse that's right do you think that
that is something that the US could
effectively manage or even emotionally
except we may not be that may be an
eventual tap we'd we may not need to do
that anytime soon there are so many
other things industrial reuse other
forms of reuse and it's you know the
first two issues are really about
optimizing reuse in the use of
desalination and then continuing down
other paths Singapore has been more
aggressive we can do it there's no
reason we shouldn't do meagan some
people complain that that some of these
water solutions like desalination are
just enormous li energy intensive and
they have their own carbon footprint
associated with them some people suggest
that really a lot of our needs could be
addressed simply by conservation do you
think conservation is is is largely an
answer
do you think they're there what's the
point of no-return with conservation
yeah so I want to point out that there's
not just a carbon footprint but there's
also air mission externalities
associated with this electricity
consumption as well as chemical
consumption so we've done a lot of work
to try to quantify that and in many
cases we find that these air mission
externalities are even larger than the
public health benefits of treating some
of these water sources
so really the smog is worse than that
the harmful smog is worse diffic
applications and some specific required
best availment that's the best available
treatment technologies and there can be
some real trade-offs in the air emission
externalities associated with water
treatment especially if we're using very
energy-intensive water treatment
processes like mechanical vapor
recompression and crystallization where
you're taking water and you're basically
evaporating all that water and making a
pure salt so we do need to think about
what those trade-offs are and I think
that doing so in a quantitative manner
helps us to make wise decisions I also
think that much like in the energy
efficiency space thinking about water
efficiency is likely to be the lowest
cost and and certainly the least
impactful opportunity well the the most
the least environmentally impactful
opportunity for reducing the energy
intensity of water treatment and of
water supply that conservation can come
through retrofitting of our
infrastructure systems for water
delivery it's also already happened
quite a bit through innovation in our
appliances but there's a number of
existing opportunities to think about
conservation and water recycling that
that still need a lot of work okay
Veolia runs a number of water utilities
even at the national level in some
countries in in the energy sector we've
often struggled to have our power
suppliers accept and embrace energy
conservation because it simply means
less revenue for the power producer and
they're stuck with the same amount of
infrastructure
and less revenue for their
infrastructure to the same situations
apply for water utilities and if so are
there any clever solutions to solving
that problem so there's two models in
what our utilities there is one where
the UT doesn't own the assets so
basically the utility is just an
operator of the asset that's typically
what we do in many many cases so in that
case the revenue I guess you will always
probably have a biased like you
mentioned so yes we but I think in that
case there is also an incentive
sometimes in different cities would
incentivize consumption I think it's
very important to really look at at this
upstream reduction of usage and then the
second second model is okay then we also
are a capital investor in the project so
but that's not what the companies like
ourselves would do but there is also
private utilities which also basically
put the money and only the assets and I
guess but but you know what the utility
is I mean it's again a partnership with
local cities with a region to define an
agenda at a certain scale and then you
push that agenda in and the water
utility is part of that agenda and then
so conservation just becomes one of the
elements in water strategy yeah that is
defined on a higher level and a basin
level maybe on a water basin level and
then you basically abide by certain
guidelines and you have certain
incentives to you know to minimize that
your consumption yeah great I'm going to
encourage audience members to send in
some questions we've already gotten some
wonderful questions here and here's one
that I I like a lot the audience member
asks oh what about the use of
desalination plants as a flexible load
so how can water treatment be actually
used collaboratively with energy
generation and energy supply Meghan do
you have any thoughts on that
graduate students to answer this
question but he might have been the one
asking the question you know now yes so
so I think that there are some
trade-offs these are typically pretty
capital intensive treatment plants and
so you don't want to over build water
treatment capacity and if you are
concerned about you know if you're going
to be operating a capacity factor for
your water treatment facility that's
only 20% but you still need to supply
your municipal water you know your
miscible water needs
you're not going to upsize that plant by
five times so you need to think about
what are the trade-offs and capital
costs and operational costs making this
a somewhat difficult play for a
desalination plant and we're doing some
some work right now particularly in
distribution systems to understand what
sort of capacity there is to shift the
load for pumping and what implications
that might have for water quality in the
distribution system as well
and then I think the other the other
piece that is is really important to
think about is smaller scale more
distributed systems and particularly
that have intermittent treatment needs
and in those situations I think that
there's a lot more potential for either
load balancing or use of intermittent
renewable resources to help power some
of those water treatment technologies
thank you I want to comment on that sure
you know there's there's tremendous
opportunity in hybrid desalination which
involves you know the to the leading
technology is membrane based he's
foundation but you know there are
opportunities to hybridize them with
thermal desalination where you optimize
waste heat from an off taker
we believe that solar is going to play a
very important role in the future and
driving down costs because these
nations or desalination plants are
usually in Sun rich areas and those are
there's there's an array of things and
with automation the ability to optimize
and balance things it's a whole new
frontier so there's a lot of
opportunities but as I said recycling
water and desalination is really the
solution but desalination has tremendous
scope for optimization okay you know
Veolia do you also run power facilities
yeah we're not no power facilities we
run power systems like cooling cooling
yeah this free cooling district heating
yeah I have two interesting examples one
from a Swiss friend who tells me you
know we have got you good you guys
because what they do very interesting
you know that the power plant you know
has excess capacity at night depending
how power is produced with nuclear you
don't want to go up and down so what
they have done is fantastic they bought
the cheap power at night you know what
they do with it they pump water at night
they bring water up the Alps at night
and then they resell the electricity
when it's high and it's hydroelectric
power so this type of thing is possible
we also had a project where we are
looking at a power plant also having
excess capacity at night and then we
costed a desalination plant to do a
storage because storage of energy is the
big issue right energy storage at the
end of that is all about energy storage
so can you use water to store energy and
how do you do that so one way is the
Swiss way pump up but then we are
looking at this Allan ating water during
night and then doing what is called
aquifer storage and recovery so you take
this a netted water put it in the
aquifer and then you know you basic
that's energy that you have saved and
then so the our project is not so many
but it's it's gonna happen more and more
so wait a minute so you could you could
go to this how is it Mount Washington
here you could potentially put a tank at
the top of the hill and and pump water
up from the river in the middle of the
night and then so there these times I
suppose be small there he lies to be
steep you know there are some conditions
but yeah you can know they got some
steep hills here I think so turning now
towards maybe a closer issue so city of
Pittsburgh I'm familiar with with there
system it was one of the water systems
that my company dealt with and city of
Pittsburgh has had a range of challenges
over the years with with treating and
preventing water one was led a number of
the components of the distribution
system in Pittsburgh have led and Ave
Veolia has has been in operations with
respect to Pittsburgh what have what
have we learned both from the specific
challenges with managing Pittsburgh
systems and what do we learn in general
about older municipal water distribution
systems so I am in a global industrial
division so I have to admit I know very
little about the specific here and I am
not pleased to talk about it more on the
complex industrial projects but I think
what we learn all is water chemistry is
very important and so in utilities you
know we need to pay a lot of attention
to that chemistry I mean as the
infrastructure you know is aging we have
concrete we have some metals we have
some and we had we had a chemistry that
was optimized for that anyway I'm
talking in industries the same corrosion
is a big deal and so we have to really
pay attention to to that but again I
cannot comment about because I've I am
NOT it's a different division in
operation who was involved in that sure
so I really I really am not sure well
another area that affected Pittsburgh
was issues related to the discharge of
treated water from the oil and gas
industry Megan what were some of the
issues that Pittsburgh encountered there
and what were their solutions I have a
colleague Jean vamp reason in civil
environmental engineering who's done a
lot of work on understanding the impacts
of bromide discharges on the formation
of disinfection by-products and drinking
water treatment plants and there if you
have high concentrations of chlorides
and bromides it can accelerate and
enhance the formation of chlorinated or
brominated organics during the drinking
water treatment process so in other
words the the same stuff that we use to
disinfect the water to
make it clean and safe for us to drink
also has the potential for unintended
consequences with formation of
byproducts that's correct and we have
disinfection by-product regulations in
place to make sure that those
concentrations are at levels that
minimize the risks to public health
while still ensuring that you're getting
water that does not have lots of
bacteria or virus in it but modulating
and ensuring that you're in compliance
with that regulation and can be tough
when we have low river flow conditions
so in the summertime when it's dry and
or when there's a large amount of either
cooling water from power plants or oil
and gas discharge water both of which
are high in these chlorides and bromides
so we all share the same water and
whether we like it or not water and
energy and extra quickly linked pinky
the oil and gas sector has sometimes
been criticized about their treatment of
water and some people suggested that
there really is no that that water and
oil don't mix you know that there is no
conceivable way in the long run for the
oil and gas sector not to damage our
water sector you're in the water
treatment business for this sector what
are your thoughts well I think those
comments are usually not well-founded on
facts the technology does exist to be
able to support full environmental
stewardship and and I think that
producers typically want to meet
environmental stewardship standards so I
think everything's there to do it I do
agree with Meghan and that's what's
going on in the in most of the plays is
that maximizing recycle at this point
her reuse of water is happening and as
they progress as every mentioned you'll
continue on a continuum of technology
needs that will be supported with more
and more
technologies especially as fields become
mature so yeah so so it is it is well
within our means to effectively treat
water some people have been concerned
about the contamination of drinking
water aquifers from produced water is
that a serious issue in Pennsylvania you
know I don't think so I mean I think
that responsible treatment is out there
it's well regulated well another factor
is that sometimes oil and gas is
produced at a far deeper level and the
earth than the than the aquifer is where
we draw our drinking water so there's
actually some physical separation in
some cases
looking ahead there's a lot of
innovation in artificial intelligence
machine learning how do you think that
those technologies are going to affect
how we design water infrastructure and
operate water treatment systems yeah
they don't ok we can raise our hands a
lot have you seen some creative examples
already or any surprises that you've
seen in how those technologies can and
cannot affect water treatment yeah I am
making a presentation on that in Asia in
a couple of weeks I think definitely a
lot we will need sensors we are going to
need reliable sensors because data is
based on the and information so we have
some sensors but we need more sensors
reliable we have seen drones
that's how yeah there will be a lot what
is it gonna be the industry is asking
itself how is it going to shape our
industry in fact it's but there will be
changes other industries have been
changed and the water industry will
probably be also changed by it so yeah
Megan are you seeing any interesting
frontier areas of research for machine
learning artificial intelligence and
water yes so I think that there's
actually lots of applications across
many different scales there are
applications in water resource
management understanding where there's
water supply using satellite data
understand things about snow cover and
when we expect to see peak flows etc
there's applications at the process
level ensuring that your processes are
running at their most efficient possible
sort of standards and and energy
efficiency particularly when that comes
to operating these systems dynamically
either to respond to variable water
quality or changes in the required
treatment volume particularly if you did
want to pair this with intermittent
energy sources and then I think there's
also applications in machine learning
and and advanced computational tools in
terms of actually designing the
materials that are going into water
treatment processes and so there's a
number of examples here at Carnegie
Mellon of people who are doing materials
based research that's leveraging
computational tools both to predict
material properties but also to optimize
those properties pinky where is sort of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence land in the product and
technology roadmap for your company well
I think just taking a step back the you
know we're still one of the things we
struggle with every day as the issues of
cybersecurity Zoar clients face and
willingness to share data and there's a
paradigm shift needed in you know the
industrial water technology world lives
in a reactive alarm based culture and we
have to move to sensing and predictive
diagnostics so before we can move to
optimization and prevention and and I
think that shift along with the cyber
security challenges will you know open
up a huge frontier the the opportunity
is is vast to drive performance but you
know we need more cost-effective sensing
technology and it has to be sensing the
things we need today the types of things
we put in our systems aren't what we
need to sense so there there's a lot of
change needed at that basic level and
CMU's at the forefront of integration
of automation across different fields
whether it be chemical engineering
material science and computer
engineering and I think they're very
well positioned okay we're coming up on
the end of our time so I want to ask one
final question for each of you and turn
it back towards the individual we've
talked a lot about water and energy
infrastructures but ultimately water and
water use comes down to people so I'm
curious Venki for you and your family
and the future as we continue in a world
where we have more climate uncertainty
where we continue in a world where water
resources may be more and more precious
what changes do you think individuals
should think about in terms of their
personal water use and how they interact
with the world of water well my wife
reminds me about how much water I use in
my shower every day I tell her well we
we save water around the world every day
she says doesn't matter and I think
thinking is important as far as what we
do personally because every I think
every drop counts Megan what do you
think for the personal use in the future
I think we need to remember that a very
large fraction somewhere between 70 or
so percent of our water is actually used
in agricultural sector so some of the
the most effective ways that you can
personally change our water footprint is
to change your food foot food footprints
nope or hamburgers Oh Peter okay okay
what do you what lessons do you take
both and maybe some lessons you've seen
from other countries that have dealt
with water scarcity more than States no
I think first on a personal level I
think I have three daughters I think
education is very important I think we
need to educate our young children very
early on you know water what is water
you know bacteria what is bacteria you
know so they are not afraid of bacteria
but I think it's a education education
is very important now what there is
worldwide water there's a no border you
know evaporation and then cloud so so I
think water is also a good place to to
exchange between countries between
people we have the same problems and
it's a ground that is a bit more neutral
so I think it's a fantastic place for
partner
chips hmm and things like that so I
think what there is so maybe even the
most contentious places on earth right
now we can all agree to one thing and
that is water is an important part of
our future all right with that everybody
thank I want to thank our panelists
again and thank the audience for these
fabulous questions and we look forward
to the rest of the day thank you
everybody
[Applause]
all right everyone we're gonna keep the
goodness going we have another good
panel for you up next we do have a break
scheduled after this session so if you
can hang tight for another 45 minutes
you'll have an opportunity for coffee
snacks and other at that time my name is
Jacob ward I wear two hats I'm both a
PhD student here at Carnegie Mellon
University I'm also the program manager
for analysis at the US Department of
Energy
so especially excited to be able to wear
both hats at this event today our next
panel is smart cities transportation
infrastructure electrification and the
autonomous sharing economy I'm happy to
announce an exceptional set of panelists
including Kostas Samaras who is not only
the moderator but also my PhD advisor an
assistant professor of civil and
environmental engineering here at
Carnegie Mellon University his research
spans energy climate change vehicle
automation and defense analysis and he
directs the Center for engineering and
resilience for climate adaptation he is
an affiliated faculty member in Carnegie
Mellon's Scott Institute for energy
innovation the College of Engineering
energy science technology and policy
program and by courtesy a faculty member
in the H John Heinz of third college
Kosta is also an adjunct senior
researcher at the RAND Corporation not
next to Costa but framing Costa will do
sandwich introductions we have joe
dimaggio director of business
development for Duquesne Light Company
Joe is the director of business
development there he is responsible for
identifying and executing on new
investment opportunities in developing
the company's long term business
strategy including its role in advancing
transportation electrification jumping
across the stage a little bit there we
have Darren Epps who's a product
development specialists who helps lead
electric transportation efforts at
atlanta-based Southern companies energy
and from an innovation center mr. Epps
is currently focused on developing and
next generation electric vehicle charger
second use electric vehicle programs and
innovative turnkey charging bundles for
municipalities and fleets we also have
another colleague of mine Sarah Alexa
back here on your left-hand side of the
stage
she is the energy efficient Mobility
Systems Manager at the u.s.
of energy where she manages
transportation projects that help smart
cities increase energy efficiency and
reduce emissions through the convergence
of connectivity automation shared
mobility multimodal urban transport and
Evi charging infrastructure she also
wears lots of hats back on the other
side of the stage we have Corinna Rick's
the director of the city of Pittsburgh
Department of mobility and
infrastructure the department is
responsible for the transportation of
people and goods throughout the city of
Pittsburgh and for managing the
operation of and access to the public
right-of-way and finally in the center
we have sherry Shapiro who is the senior
manager of public affairs for
Pennsylvania and Delaware for uber
sherry leads ubers public and government
affairs efforts in Pennsylvania and
Delaware she spearheaded Ebert's
successful campaign in 2016 to legalize
ride-sharing across Pennsylvania please
look on our panel and cost it with that
I give it to you all for being here and
it's an honor to be introduced by one of
our great graduate students co-advised
with some of my colleagues here in the
Scott Institute for energy innovation
and to be joined by such an illustrious
panel of transportation leaders our
panel today is about the future and
about the future of smart cities future
transportation the integration with the
sharing economy the integration with the
electricity sector and I wanted to
mention that today the Scott Institute
for energy innovation kicked off our our
latest update for our emissions index
that you can find out emissions index
org and that helps us understand the
impacts of maybe charging electric
vehicles or using electricity across the
country so I invite all of you all to
visit that website before we get too
deep into that I wanted to start here by
understanding the future of a place like
Pittsburgh and we can I'm gonna ask the
panel and we'll start with Karina you
know help us imagine what a smart city
means to everyday folks and what the
future of a place like Pittsburgh means
to everyday people and maybe you can
help us understand what will a place
like Pittsburgh look like in 25 years
from a transportation or energy respect
I think we're looking out 25 years it's
really helpful to look backwards to see
where we've been
maybe not 25 years but but maybe looking
back 40 years when Pittsburgh was a city
twice its size
we were 600,000 plus people in this city
we had a robust economy many many people
the primary commuting modes at that time
were walking using one of our 770 sets
of stairs to get to and from the mills
we had a expansive transit system we're
continuously digging up rails that I
didn't even know existed underneath our
streets of the vast streetcar system
that once plied the city but we also had
a lot of challenges we had horrific air
quality we had very compromised rivers
we paid a price for that economic
robustness that we had in the city so I
think looking forward when we look
forward 25 years I think we take the
best of the past but we also learned
from it make a smart city when we talk
about energy when we talk about and at
CMU inevitably autonomy that we also
need to think about those lesser
celebrated modes of walking and
bicycling and transit use the city of
the future that I see is one where we
again see walking and bicycling as being
some of the primary means of getting
around the city especially for those
very short trips that make up more than
60% of the trips that we make in our
daily lives when I think about autonomy
and electrification I really want to see
that pushed into the transit sector not
necessarily the low capacity autonomous
vehicles but higher capacity buses
trains and others that ply our city so
that we can really dramatically reduce
the operational costs of that mode and
have a level of service that is as as
great as we enjoyed during peak hour
with very marginal costs additional to
that system and so we're single occupant
or low occupancy electric all-electric
autonomous mobility really is an
ancillary supplement
that backbone system where the majority
of our travel is taken by bicycling
walking and transit right so sherry
what does it look like for uber in
what's Ebers vision of a future city 25
years from now first I want to say that
it looks a lot like what Karina just
articulated the idea for uber is to have
a very multimodal means of
transportation public transit will
always be the most efficient and the
most environmentally beneficial way for
people to get from place to place
bicycles and walking but so it will be a
very multimodal universe powered by
electricity or something better if we
can get there and most importantly for
us both electric and shared shared is
really a piece of this that we need to
bring in beyond just public transit but
shared rides in individual cars as well
something along the lines of 70% of
trips now are taken in cars with one
person in them if we don't start
shifting that mindset as well as adding
the electric and autonomous pieces to it
we'll be missing out on a great
opportunity to benefit cities so you
mentioned the electric part I remember
maybe we can go over to Joe and help us
understand how an electric utility
especially a local distribution company
views what a smart city looks like 25
years from now sure thanks yeah both the
Korean and Sherry's comments I think we
recognized that the city 25 years from
now in that in the transportation sector
electricity is going to be potentially
the primary fuel source at least a much
more substantial fuel source so I was
actually looking at some projections
preparing for our talk today and some
industry outlooks are actually
forecasting that over 50
of light-duty passenger cars by 2040
will be evey so that's that's a massive
shift from boy from where we're at today
so as the utility in the provider of
that fuel source we're taking steps now
to prepare ourselves for that future so
to excuse me the spring of last year we
made an announcement of strategic
announcement that that we were going to
be advancing and playing a strategic
role advancing transportation
electrification in the region
we started by electrifying our own fleet
so to really learn the benefits of and
the operations of electric vehicles we
actually now we have eighteen vehicles
that have been electrified in our own
fleet and then over the next several
years really for the foreseeable future
we're projecting to invest nearly 20
percent of our annual fleet budget in
electric vehicles so so some significant
investment on that front and then really
taking the next step
looking at deploying charging
infrastructure to understand how how
charging a vehicles impacts our
distribution system that's another
massive step that we're taking and
really illustrated by the partnership
that we announced earlier this year with
uber so as we're trying to increase the
number of uber evie drivers do keen
lights really going to play the role
into helping deploy that the fast
charging infrastructure that's needed
for those who buries drivers so so those
are some of the steps that that we're
taking to prepare ourselves for for that
for that shift in the transportation
sector in the future there may be you
can build on that coming from a
different type of utility our our
utilities ready for this type of
environment what can they do I think
we're getting ready now I think we're
getting ready now there we go I think we
see the future of transportation as
connected autonomous shared and electric
the question we're working to solve is
how would you support the infrastructure
to autonomous fully and we talked about
that backstage I'm sorry to report we
did not come up with any solutions but
we you know right now cars are parked
96% of the time
that is a market that's asking to be
disruptive disruptive right now my car's
been at the Atlanta Airport since
yesterday I'll be there today tomorrow
just sitting there doing nothing could
it be putting power back on the grid I
Drive a Nissan Leaf in the future state
yes could it be working for me right now
and delivering goods in the future state
I think I think it will we talk all the
time to builders in Atlanta who are
putting up parking structures and they
are trying to think about how to build a
parking structure for the next 50 years
and do they build the parking deck so it
can be easily converted in to say more
condos because I think everyone sees
this happening it's happening right now
bringing up the Atlanta Airport again
they had plans to add a lot more parking
and they tore them up because you know
it's it's cheaper if you're gonna be at
the airport for two or three or four
more days to just take an uber to the
airport instead of parking and paying 16
a day so in that in that same vein we
think the cars will be electric because
the cost per mile is so much lower when
you drive an electric versus gas so that
that's sort of how just building on
everyone else's point out how we see the
future of mobility in Atlanta and beyond
great so the Sarah works at the
Department of Energy which is a
multi-headed organization as many of you
know mostly responsible for the design
and safeguarding of a nuclear weapons
system as well as the advancement of you
know high energy physics and science a
small part of that which we think is a
very important part is kind of
developing the next generation of our
energy technology and maybe Sarah you
can give us an understanding of how is
the Department of Energy preparing for
this world of shared automated electric
transportation and what are the things
on the horizon that we might be able to
expect at the Department of Energy soon
our biggest goals to to help cities move
forward in the next 25 years we're
working alongside the Department of
Transportation to make mobility more
equitable make it more accessible and
make it more affordable to everyday
American consumers drivers of vehicles
so what we're working on always is for
example with electric vehicles is going
to be investments in research and
development to bring down the costs of
the vehicles so we do that primarily are
the largest portion of our budget goes
toward improving battery capacity and
battery resilience through since 2008
we've brought down battery costs by
eighty percent that's significant and we
still have so much room to go further on
the other side of the coin we're working
to increase the battery capacity so
every year automakers that we're working
with in partnership are putting out
vehicles that have higher and higher
longer and longer vehicle ranges so
again this goes back to making these
vehicles more affordable and more
convenient for drivers and it's not just
about making mobility more convenient
with electric vehicles but we still have
to think about all those traditional
internal combustion engine vehicles on
the road as well so how are we making
those vehicles more fuel efficient as
well and we're making big gains there
through the advancements in
high-strength steel light weighting
reducing rolling resistance and tires so
there's just a lot of gains that can be
made with increasing vehicle efficiency
and I'll talk a little bit more later
probably about some of the systems level
work that we're doing right well sherry
you mentioned the importance of sharing
and how do we get to sharing we know
that sharing is helpful for the
environmental impacts of automation and
and for transportation but do we think
sharing is likely and what are the some
of the barriers to sharing and I get
asked a lot will autonomous vehicles be
shared or where they be privately owned
or will it be a combination of both what
are your thoughts on that so let's go to
the experience that we
had goober has a product in many cities
called uber pool and uber pool is
exactly what it sounds like a pickup one
passenger and then you pick up another
passenger who's going in the same route
and direction and then you drop them off
the two barriers to carpooling have
historically been inconvenience you go
with Larry and morning Larry has to stay
late for a meeting and you've lost your
ride home and cost right it's easier and
less expensive to simply drive your own
car no aggravation what we found is that
through technology this has really
broken through on the first primary
barrier by pooling people by trip as
opposed to by individual person you get
rid of that inconvenience and
uncertainty factor that's really been a
huge change also people will carpool if
the cost is low enough so by having
pooled rides lowers the cost and
therefore people are more likely to take
them what we've found is in pool cities
about 20% of our rights our pool rights
and that is growing and we're doing
continual improvement to the pool
product excellent well I mean the the
comments that that Carina made in the
beginning which is about looking
backward and thinking about her past got
me thinking about our previous
transportation revolutions and how they
really opened up a lot of new access and
mobility for whole bunch of different
populations another thing that they also
did was sometimes bisect neighborhoods
wall off neighborhoods destroy
neighborhoods and I wonder how we can
make choices at the beginning of this
transportation revolution with the
hindsight of the things that we've done
wrong in the past so that we don't
repeat some of those mistakes and how
could a smart city also improve equity
environmental justice and access
it's a big question and it's something
that we really need to wrestle with
again back in the city of the past when
walking and bicycling in transit were
the dominant modes of travel we did have
less transportation and equity these are
very democratic forms of mobility the
the costs are very flat across the board
today the cost of owning and operating a
private automobile is about $10,000 a
year 920 I'm sorry 99 thousand two
hundred dollars per year according to
triple-a for every year that you own and
operate a vehicle and that's before you
pay for parking so that cost can go
significantly up that's per car per year
so for households that are earning below
the the median income that is a
substantial cost and the Pennsylvania
western Pennsylvania region our
households that are in the lower fifth
quintile of income their household
transportation costs are nearly double
what their household housing costs are
so transportation costs are about double
what housing costs are for the lowest
quintile income earners in the region so
it's very important that in part is
because we've built a society now in
this age that does require the owning
and operation and maintenance of a
private automobile if you are to get to
a number of the job centers that some of
the lowest income earners are most apt
to be matched with these job centers are
out in the suburban districts these job
centers are job reporting times are in
non peak times they're in the off-peak
periods and very difficult to get to we
no longer really have that walk centric
urban form we no longer really have the
kind of ubiquitous transit service that
we had so I think again I'll keep
hitting this drum of autonomous electric
shared mobility means mass transit to
the extent that it can for cities that's
the best way that we can do it we have
3,000 mass transit vehicles
in Allegheny County we have hundreds of
thousands of privately owned vehicles so
we really the way to the future is to
expand that transit fleet increase mass
transit usage increase the efficiency
convenience and attractiveness of that
mode that can decrease the environmental
consequences which again
disproportionately affect to lower
income populations more isolated
populations it can increase their access
to jobs and employment and can help them
raise their standard of living my
department is a new department and I
like to sort of repeat the mission that
we've adopted which is which is drawn
from research done in Harvard University
that says that commuting is the single
largest factor that influences a
households ability to escape poverty
their access to transportation is more
important on the quality of the schools
or the quality of the housing in these
areas and so the mission of my
department is to provide the physical
mobility that's necessary for the
economic mobility that people seek and
and we do this through the promotion of
shared electric autonomy shared electric
mobility that does really again
democratize access to economic
opportunity excellent well we the theme
that we keep hearing is shared electric
mobility Joe and Darren mentioned some
of the things that the utilities are
doing to prepare the grid for potential
charging but maybe you can give us a
sense about some of the barriers to
electric vehicle mass adoption and and
when we might see a whole bunch of these
vehicles on the road maybe we start with
dinner so I think one of the barriers
right now and Ann mentioned this earlier
is going to be the infrastructure if you
look at the electric vehicle market
right now they're the models are getting
more sophisticated the battery batteries
are getting bigger the ranges are
getting longer the technology is getting
better for charging what's not kept up
as much as the infrastructure in that
and that's because there's a tough ROI
on
on infrastructure you know a fast
charger is about $30,000 could be 20 to
40 and installation and you're charging
$2 you know an hour that's that's a long
time to get your money back so like Ann
said earlier a regulatory process that
helps the utility consider charging
infrastructure as an extension of the
grid I think would be a lot better you
know we were looking at 350 kilowatt
hour charging right now
hi-hi-hi power charging I think this
changes and probably around 2025 so when
you look at the what it costs to drive a
gas vehicle what you just mentioned that
has continued to go up as regulations
get gets stronger the cost to buy an
electric vehicle continues to go down
and I think around 2025 those lines meet
and at that point it's just cheaper to
buy an electric vehicle than a gas
vehicle even without considering the
savings of fuel costs the savings and
maintenance so I think 2025 is kind of
the date we have we have pegged I think
it's um what was some of the automakers
have pegged as when the parity cost
parity is reached with gas and electric
vehicles Joey you have any ad on that
front yeah I mean just I agree with a
lot of the things that Darren said and
if you look at as far as the 2025 date I
think that coincides with many of the
major automakers have announced over the
past several months billions and
billions and billions of dollars that
they're investing in vehicle
electrification Ford announced that
they're going to be investing I think 11
billion dollars by 2022 GM's gonna have
20 additional Eevee models they kind of
you run through the list of all the
major auto manufacturers and and these
companies are focusing significant
dollars in this space and I think you
know I've always kind of went by the old
adage of you follow the money and
they're investing the money in this
space and I think with that with the
decrease in battery cost that was
mentioned by Sarah earlier you're gonna
hit a point where it just makes more
sense the performance of the electric
vehicle is better you don't have to take
it into the shop to get the oil change
so
there's just a lot of benefits to
driving electric and they're just a
couple other points you know locally I
think that we're not as mature in
western Pennsylvania some other evie
markets you know there's roughly 1500
vehicles within our Duquesne Light
service territory EVs that are
registered as at the end of the year so
we we still have some barriers to cross
as far as education goes so that's that
that's something that we're trying to do
is the utility we're trying to educate
our customers where we've been the title
sponsor at the Pittsburgh Home & Garden
Show for 20 plus years I think now so
the past couple of years we've put
together a significant piece of our
exhibit has been dedicated purely to to
electric vehicle education it's part of
the partnership with uber a big
component of that we'll be partnering
with the local nonprofit to be
determined to help educate over drivers
that will in turn help educate Hooper
riders so we think that that crossing
that education barrier is another
significant piece for a market that's
still kind of at the early stages that
we are at here in Western PA great well
so one of the things that we've done at
Carnegie Mellon for a long time through
my colleagues at the vehicle
electrification group is understanding
the environmental impacts of so maybe
Sarah you can help us understand will
shared automated electric vehicles be
any better for the environment what if I
were to live you know two hours away and
and and start driving a lot more what is
the grid gonna look like how do we
assess if these are gonna be good or not
it's a great question and conveniently
the Department of Energy has a brand new
program that we've just stood up to
answer these questions it's called the
energy efficient mobility systems
program and if there's any for all the
students that are in the room if you
want an exciting hot area to do research
in and hint-hint there may be money here
in the near near future there already is
but there will be more check out Google
do e energy efficient mobility systems
and so what this program is doing is its
looking to understand how we increase
this is a new metric mobility energy Pro
activity so how do we increase the the
bang for the buck that we get on every
unit of goods or people moved we know
that with the advent of autonomous
vehicles and increase in shared mobility
that VMT is likely going to rise we
think that there is going to be an
increased accessibility for more people
to move more and the administration is
very supportive of that we should not be
hindering people's accessibility and
ability to move but how do we do it in
the most energy efficient way so of
course this is looking at increased use
of mass transit increased use of shared
mobility limiting empty miles driven and
doing all of this in the most energy
efficient way possible and we're not
just talking about them when we think
about smart cities and energy and
mobility a lot of people think strictly
of electric vehicles and I just want
people to be thinking about how much
bigger it is than that it's not just EVs
it's about doing all of our mobility in
the most efficient way possible and so
what the energy efficient mobility
systems program is doing is we're
starting to think with cities how do we
harness the power of data the massive
amounts of data that we have access to
in our mobility systems and use that to
increase the efficiency of those systems
and so working with partners like uber
for example actually in one of our
living labs projects we're looking at
how we can do just that
so we're doing work in five activity
areas but - that all highlight is the
smart mobility laboratory consortium
which five national labs NREL Idaho
National Lab Oak Ridge National Lab
Argonne National Lab and Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab are all part of
we're doing research on advanced fueling
infrastructure needs connect in an
automated vehicle
urban science in a couple other new
discipline areas where we're standing up
just new fundamental basic research
endeavors in this space to understand
the energy impacts with these
technologies and then our living labs
projects are kind of the the real world
technology integration or deployment of
these technologies and we're recording
data and we're getting working with
cities and the private sector to look at
this data and understand how we can make
more increase our mobility energy
productivity so definitely check out
those programs and an early finding when
we stood the program up we did a very
high-level bounding study just don't
connect connected and automated vehicles
and we found that there is the potential
to increase energy consumption by 200
percent or decrease energy consumption
by just making sure I have it right
sixty percent so that is a huge range
and it just shows how much more work is
needed in this space hence the dollars
going into investments in research to
understand this better and help cities
make choices that are going to steer
them in the more energy-efficient
direction so you mentioned choices share
you want to add to that I was asking
what the policy landscape what is the
choice what are those choices right so
right so it's it's interesting you
should say that one of the areas that we
are particularly supportive of at uber
is congestion pricing are people making
the right decisions about what mode of
transportation to make at the right
times so you're really maximizing the
efficiency and the use of the most
efficient mode for the time of day or
activity and that is a really strong
lever that has been shown to work in the
different places that it's been in in
place like London and to use that lever
to achieve the goals that Sarah was
articulating Carina what do you think
about the policy landscape to encourage
some of the better outcomes in this
smarter City environment
what are some of the bigger choices that
we might be needing to consider over the
next 10 to 15 years well I would concur
with sherry that we do need to
understand sort of what the monetization
of that there is a cost but the actual
cost as well as a social cost associated
with our mobility choices coming from
the city it also means that our revenues
will actually change we do get a
significant amount of revenue from from
parking for example and a shared an
autonomous mobility future it does mean
that we need to think about that
differently the significant costs the
significant revenue that funds the
investment in infrastructure and the
maintenance of our transportation
facilities is from liquid fuels tax
which we're all delighted to see go away
but we do need to then replace those
revenue sources with something else
because we're still going to need the
streets and bridges and sidewalks and
lights that we use there and so really
that's some of the critical questions
that are in front of cities right now
and States as well is to understand how
do we promote this great green
transformation to more sustainable modes
of mobility which we very very much want
to see thrive and be adopted but at the
same time we need to backfill that so
that they can continue to fund the
maintenance and operations of our
transportation systems given that the
that the federal gas tax has not been
raised or indexed for inflation since
what's the appetite for of vehicle miles
traveled feet so vehicle miles traveled
there's I think that there's great
appetite for it and conceptually it
seems like a very good idea there's a
lot of issues associated with that in
various tests have been done to evaluate
that one of the issues is that
right now the the liquid fuels tax is
gathered at point of sale so if you're
driving on the Turnpike between Ohio and
Pennsylvania if you fuel up at a
Pennsylvania rest stop Pennsylvania gets
your money if you fuel up in Ohio rest
stop
Ohio gets your money if it's vehicle
miles traveled we now have privacy
concerns as to understand where you're
traveling when and how far and at what
time so that's sherry mentioned that's
one of the challenges with congestion
pricing as well is that it does sort of
indicate a need for tracking you in a
way so there's still some bugs to be
worked out on the vehicle miles traveled
we've also talked Robin chase who's been
a real leader in this space around
shared an autonomous mobility has talked
a lot about having sort of a a volume
tax for lack of a better term which is
understanding if a human being generally
can travel taking up the space of about
you know three cubic feet in surface
area if you start to use modes like
private vehicle travel which actually
consume about a thousand square feet if
you're the only one in that vehicle
versus a higher occupancy mode that you
would you would then be charged for that
usage utilization of the right-of-way
and calculating it in various ways like
that yeah it's so interesting so a space
based tax rather than a weight or
efficiency tax yes there and that that's
important to figure out a new model
because in Georgia anyone who drives an
electric vehicle to make up with a gas
tax
they charge you every day every day on
my birthday
I get two hundred dollar registration
fee to make this order make up for the
lack of fuel I'm using meanwhile the
average SUV driver pays about 130 in gas
tax a year so I pay more than anybody in
the state in gas tax so there are nuts
need to be a discussion about a
different model to assess those speeds
because I as a needy driver I want the
roads to be great I want to pay my share
but it's it's it's not fair the way
currently set up and in other states are
starting to follow suit well as a
recovering transportation engineer I'm
going to
point you and say that neither you nor
the SUV is causing much road damage it's
it's nearly all heavy trucks that are
that are damaging the road on on a day
to day basis and there is a cross
subsidy between cars bikes SUVs towards
towards the heavy trucks owner on our
roadways but and I'm obligated to say
snow snow winter yes in our salting of
the roads a lot of this has been talked
about with the electrification of the
transportation sector as pretty key
towards this smart city and an advanced
mobility concept Joe and Darrin have
talked about the ability of the
infrastructure what about the generation
assets and and how we might continue to
see generation assets play into this
into this space will there be a lot of
distributed generation in cities 15
years from now or is it gonna be a more
still kind of centralized grid operation
chummy you start would you start with
Joe or you want to start there yeah I
could I could I can kick that one off no
I think we're we're seeing more and more
interest in from a customer perspective
and with costs coming down on
distributor generation I do think that
you're going to see an uptick or you
know a greater prevalence of distributed
generation you know the recent first
energy solutions bankruptcy filing the
statements that they've made regarding
closing some of their their biggest
Central Station facilities I think that
those are indicative of the time that
we're in so with that you know it's it's
imperative that we that we invest in our
distribution grid our distribution and
transmission grid assets to make sure
that we have the the capacity they have
the the ability to take in to take into
account this pearl proliferation of
distributed and energy resources and I
think it was mentioned earlier as well
vehicles could could be a distributive
energy resource in the future and I
think that as we see increased adoption
of electric vehicles that that's just
another asset that we're going to have
to manage and then we're going to have
to create a grid that is a platform to
manage all of these distributed energy
resources so we're investing those
dollars
today with an eye towards the future
that it will be an environment with with
greater distributed generation so we're
testing that right now we have two smart
neighborhoods one in Georgia and one in
Alabama that are the one in Georgia we
have rooftop solar all the appliances in
the house will be connected and smart
and we want to test how people interact
with a smart home and study how
generation works off the rooftop solar
and that will also inform our RDL so
unfortunately the future of home
building so we want to learn that the
one in Alabama is a little bit different
it has all the the whiz-bang devices in
the house but the neighborhood it's
going to be powered by a micro grid so a
different technology and again we want
to study that it does that make sense
for future home building so in both
cases we partnered with the home builder
and we're all learning a lot about the
future of homes and it's distributed
generation the answer we're also doing a
pilot in Atlanta smart cities pilot so
we own a lot of light poles in the in
the southeast and we put 200 nodes on
light poles in Atlanta and this will
help us measure has video capabilities
but help measure help the city measure a
traffic flow help people with parking
does gunshot detection that immediately
notifies the police when their sound is
made so we're learning about all this
now we have a little bit more time in
the southeast our rates are among the
lowest in the country under our current
models so but we want to learn and we
want to know what the future looks like
and that's what we're working on great
well I want to shift gears because I got
a question
starting questions from the audience and
one of them is for sherry and you know I
hesitate to ask this because it's about
a flying car and so the question is what
role do you see uber elevate to play in
in the future in this Marcie so is this
for real though I mean you're gonna tell
us we're just between us is it is it
really happening though I will tell you
so what what uber elevate is is a
commercialization of virtual take off at
No
ricky'll takeoff and landing aircraft
more easily understood as drones for
human transportation and the answer is
yes they are coming they're coming
sooner than you think we have a group in
Dallas and a partnership with Bell
Helicopter and a number of the other
aviation companies to see how that can
be part of the multimodal fleet do you
think it's gonna be
intercity or intra-city how are these
gonna work to be honest with you I don't
know down to that level of detail but
here's what I do think I think that when
you start to talk about automated
transportation we need to think beyond
what the near future the autonomous
vehicles the electric vehicles and into
what the far future might be and what I
love about coming here to Carnegie
Mellon is that so many of the people
here are taking a look and researching
and thinking about what that our future
is well one of the things we have to
worry about in the far future inside of
a smart city is new new threats and new
extreme events and maybe I want to tie
in resilience to this conversation a
little bit and how does like maybe we
start with Carina like what why does the
city even need to be resilient and how
can some of this technology enhance the
ability to cope with extreme events in
in a city
so resilience means a lot of different
things and I think that that is one of
the things we maybe need to talk about
first it's not just about you know that
we can withstand record-setting rains as
we recently or extreme temperatures or
other kinds of natural events like that
there's also social resiliency that's
necessary and I think that it's
something that really we do have to
think about in the era of autonomous
mobility increased privatization of
ability what happens to our social
cohesion to those those those ties that
bind us to one another and build that
sort of social relationship that keeps
us as a strong community this is
something that we talk a lot about the
the pressures and stressors that lie on
a city not just from the environment but
also from the social aspects of the city
and so we do think about that and I
already lost the Train of no that's
exactly where try to understand how the
some of these technologies help us
improve resilience in in in a future
city and maybe we would ask Joe as a
electricity provider will the lights
stay on more our lights are pretty
reliable in Pittsburgh right now thank
you I appreciate that but it you know as
we connect more things to the internet
do you think that that will still be the
case and then how do we make sure ensure
we protect that yeah you know I guess
we're taking measures every day to make
sure that we have a reliable resilient
grid as you said we do currently have
one but it's always keeping I'm keeping
an eye on the future right so we're
investing hundreds of millions of
dollars in a long-term infrastructure
improvement plan to to better that and
then also kind of along the lines of the
theme of distributed generation we're
going to be piloting a micro grid at our
Operations Center campus on the north
side of the city where our our primary
operations center is so whenever there
is extreme weather events we're going to
essentially hard in the electrical
infrastructure there we're going to
potentially pilot some generation
technologies there as well but basically
hardening and improving the resiliency
and the reliability of that campus which
is critical to making sure the lights
stay on for all of our customers so I'd
say that you know who knows what the
future holds but we are at this point
you know we're investing significant
dollars into preparing ourselves for for
that future there's a lot of questions
about the connection between distribute
generation and Eve
charging and so do you think that new
distributed generation assets would be
coupled with EB charging have you seen
the examples where that works and will
it happen here in Pittsburgh or in
southern territories yeah I think that's
a conversation have so like I said the
future Vivi charging if you're gonna try
to simulate the gas station experience
and be done in five minutes is what I
mentioned earlier the 350 kilowatt hour
charging that is a lot of power that is
when you look from a load shape if
you're thinking of us you know in the
rural setting on a corridor off the side
of an interstate one of those chargers I
mean the spikes would be unbelievable so
I think you have to think about pairing
with battery storage or micro grid fuel
cell I think you have to have those
conversations because that that is
what's going to move the electric
transportation market I think fat right
now fast charging 50 kilowatt hour
charging it takes about 30 minutes if
someone's in front of you you could be
there for an hour we've read about
fights at charging stations because
people are getting impatient please
don't fight people at charging stations
by the way but 350 kilowatt hour
charging sort of solves that and you
would need banks of those chargers so I
think that is while it's not something
we've seen yet I think that is that is
the future is pairing that with
distributed energy let me just chime in
there for saying cost I think this is an
important point is that we don't know
what this future looks like all that we
know is that there's going to be an
increased penetration in EVs and there's
going to be at least I believe there's
going to be an increased penetration of
distributed generation so this is a
critical time for us to be piloting
things like southern like Darren and
southern are doing that Duquesne Light
is you know is just really getting off
the ground as I said because we're at a
relatively early stage in terms of
market maturity here but it's critical
for the utility I think to be piloting
technologies now to understand how this
is going to impact our system to impact
the community that we serve so just a
you know plug there that we we need to
be piloting technologies now to better
inform us for the future
I think we might have time for one more
question is that is that okay okay so
we're in the midst of a technological
revolution in the transportation sector
but the transportation sector is now the
largest emitter of greenhouse gas
emissions and so Sara we can start with
you and anybody can chime in
what's it going to take to deeply
decarbonize the transportation sector
and when what are the timelines look
like what are the levers that need to be
pulled I think that deep decarbonisation
you know it it really comes with
diversifying from petroleum to begin
with and and that is we still have a
long road to go from there and and we're
also very supportive of shifting to CNG
use especially in medium and heavy-duty
vehicles for the emission reduction
benefits they are are available there
for those types of vehicles at the
Department of Energy we find a lot of
research and development in solar wind
geothermal to to work towards bringing
down the cost of those technologies to
to to get more renewables on the grid
so either the future of a deeply
decarbonized transportation sector
karinna I mean I'll just say again that
when we have such a huge portion of our
trips that are relatively short distance
trips that we still continue to drive
and predominantly drive in single
occupant vehicles that again creating a
walkable community a bikable community
really enticing these zero emission
modes of travel and making them more
viable in our urban environments and in
the suburban environments as well
creating Complete Streets increasing
safety really paying attention to the
human experience this pays dividends on
any number of levels well thank you I
would love for all of you to join me in
thanking our panel for a wonderful
conversation
[Music]
before you will depart off of the stage
we are at a break so we're gonna take a
few minutes much like lunch first let's
thank the panel again thank you very
much we're gonna take a break until 3:30
on the other side of this wall much like
lunch there are refreshments for us so
use the facilities across the hall get
something to eat come back in here we
have spaces up front so those of you who
are towards the back when you come back
make sure you come towards the front and
we will start again at 3:30 thank you
again to our panel